[Music]
hi
i'm carson and i'm an engineer at our
studio and i'd like to show you some
work we've been doing to make custom
theming easier inside of shiny and our
markdown to show you two different
packages the first
is bslib which allows you to essentially
style any of the components that are
rendered by your web browser
inside of an app or a document the
second
thematic allows you to essentially
translate the css styles
that you include in your browser and
allow them to
set new defaults for your static r plots
so to start using bs lib with shiny
the first thing that you're going to
want to do is to call this bstheme
function
to create a theming object which you can
then give to the theme argument
of essentially any page layout inside of
shiny
that wants to utilize bootstrap now at
least currently
by default what this is going to do is
actually upgrade your application
from using bootstrap 3 to using
bootstrap 4.
so if you happen to put this in inside
of an existing application
and you encounter any issues just know
that you can also
downgrade to bootstrap 3 when using the
bs lib package
and in the future we plan on supporting
bootstrap 5 and higher
and regardless of what bootstrap version
you're using
you can easily customize the main colors
and fonts of your application
so here i've set the background and
foreground colors
to a dark mode for my application
and then next i could choose to set some
important accent colors
like the primary or secondary color and
finally i will set
a different base font from the bootstrap
defaults
so here i'm going to use the font google
function
which does a lot of work for me in terms
of making sure that the font files
are available for the end user even if
they don't have an internet connection
and also keep in mind with this bs theme
function you have access to
hundreds of different more specific
styling settings
if you want to get more targeted with
your styles and to quickly preview a
given theme object
try out this bsteam preview function
which essentially runs a demo app
where you can see all the various
components that your theme might impact
now if you were to include a bs theme
object
inside of your own application you might
notice that the styling of your
application
doesn't propagate to the static r plots
that are generated by your shiny app
and this is one of the reasons why we
created the thematic package
if you call this thematic shiny function
just prior to running the shiny
application
then all of the static r plots that are
generated by the shiny app
will use the css styles on their
container
to set new theming defaults on the r
side
bslib also provides an interactive
theming tool
which allows you to quickly try out
different theme settings
and seeing how that theme renders in
real time
this theming tool can be used with any
shiny application
by calling the bs themer function
the only requirements is that you call
the bs themer function
inside of the server function and that
you're using this interactive themer
with bootstrap 4. also keep in mind that
if you're running this themer locally
any of the interactive changes that you
make are captured with our code
and admitted to your r console so that
you can copy paste those changes
into your theme creation now if you'd
like to use these theming tools with our
markdown
the first thing to know is that you can
pass these theme settings
into the theme parameter of an html
document
in addition if you'd like to theme your
document with the interactive themic
tool
you'll have to first add a shiny runtime
to your document's yaml matter
and then call the bs themer function
inside of the server-side code
now if you'd like these real-time
changes in the css on the page
to influence the r plots rendered by the
document
you'll first have to enable thematic and
then also make sure that you're
rendering your plots
through shiny's render plot it's also
worth noting that thematic can be used
anywhere
to create any sort of file format that
you want
we've seen it used with shiny in our
markdowns html document
to create png images where the styles
are automatically informed by css styles
however you can also enable thematic and
give it the actual color codes for a
background
foreground and accent color similar to
how we provided those things to a bs
theme object
and finally i would like to thank you
for listening as well as provide these
links to the slides as well as
documentation
where you can learn more thank you